This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you had to guess, when do you think the bicycle was invented? The basic mechanics of a bike are pretty simple. It's basically a triangle with wheels and a chain drive to propel it forward. There are no batteries, there's no engines. It seems obvious. And that's why most people guess that the bike was invented a long time ago. So, sort of curious historical fact about the bicycle is its belated arrival. This is Jody Rosen. And I'm the author of Two Wheels Good, The History and Mystery of the Bicycle.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果让你猜，你觉得自行车是什么时候发明的？自行车的机械原理非常简单。它基本上就是一个带有轮子和链条传动装置的三角形，用来推动它前进。没有电池，也没有引擎。这看起来显而易见。正因如此，大多数人都猜测自行车是很久以前发明的。关于自行车，有一个挺令人好奇的历史事实，那就是它的姗姗来迟。这位是乔迪·罗森。我是《两轮之善：自行车的历史与奥秘》一书的作者。
The early version of the bicycle known as the running machine debuted around 1817, which Jody says is weirdly late. By the time that running machine or Laufmachina comes along, we're 15 years into the era of the steam locomotive. When the bicycle started to look like the machine that we know today, it was 1885. In that same year, 1885, Karl Benz invented his first motorvagan. So the automotive age is stirring at the same moment that we finally get a perfect bicycle. It took many centuries for kind of fate and, you know, trial and error to bring us the machine itself. So in that sense, I think it's one of those devices that both feels inevitable and whose history kind of
自行车早期版本被称为“奔跑机”，大约在1817年问世，乔迪说这晚得离谱。当那种“奔跑机”或称“Laufmaschine”出现时，蒸汽机车时代已经过去15年了。直到1885年，自行车才开始看起来像我们今天所知的样子。就在同一年，1885年，卡尔·本茨发明了他的第一辆汽车。所以，当我们终于得到一辆完美的自行车时，汽车时代也正在萌芽。经历了几个世纪的命运安排和反复试验，我们才得到了这种机器。从这个意义上说，我认为它是一种既让人觉得不可避免，但其历史又在某种程度上反驳了这种必然性的装置。
belies that inevitability. It just feels like, why wasn't there a bicycle that a ferro or like a Roman was peddling around on? Jody says the reason the late rival feels wrong to lots of people is because the bike feels so natural, like something that's always been with us. The thing to my mind that makes the bike school is such a beautiful and unique machine, is this fact that the rider is both the passenger of the machine and the engine. And that's actually kind of a strange idea
它让人觉得，为什么法老或罗马人没有骑着自行车到处转呢？乔迪说，很多人觉得自行车出现得太晚是不对的，因为自行车感觉太自然了，就像一直伴随着我们一样。在我看来，自行车之所以成为如此美丽而独特的机器，是因为骑行者既是机器的乘客，也是引擎。这其实是一个相当奇怪的概念，
to be both a rider of a machine and a component of a machine. But at those moments when you're kind of on your best rides, you kind of become one with the bike in some sort of zen sense. You become inseparable from it. And there's this kind of incredible fusion or communion that a human has with a machine, which is actually a kind of an uncanny phenomenon.
既是机器的骑行者，又是机器的一个组成部分。但在你骑行状态最好的那些时刻，在某种禅意的意义上，你与自行车合二为一了。你变得与它不可分割。人类与机器之间存在着一种令人难以置信的融合或共融，这实际上是一种不可思议的现象。
It's sort of a little weird and eerie. Today, we're going to talk with Jody about the evolution of the bicycle and how it became a cultural phenomenon in the late 1800s, then a symbol of protest and a lightning rod for political controversy. And we'll find out what is next for the bike in a world built for cars. So Jody, the bicycle is a pretty simple machine, but it took decades of experiments and tinkering to get the bike that we know today. Could you take us through some of the evolution of the bike? So the running machine, or the Lauf-Machina, as it was called in German in this period,
这有点怪异和诡秘。今天，我们将与乔迪讨论自行车的演变，以及它是如何在19世纪末成为一种文化现象，随后又成为抗议的象征和政治争议的焦点。我们还将探讨在为汽车打造的世界中，自行车的未来会怎样。乔迪，自行车是一种非常简单的机器，但它经历了数十年的实验和修补才变成我们今天所知的样子。你能带我们了解一下自行车的一些演变过程吗？那么，奔跑机，或者当时德语中称之为“Lauf-Machina”的装置，
was invented around about 1817 by a guy named Karl von Draese, who was a minor German nobleman in the city of Manheim. He came from some family wealth, but he really was a kind of a tinkerer and a dreamer who was always experimenting with inventing different types of devices. And one of the things he was very interested in was the problem of travel, that is the question of how you could move across land without a horse. So he made many efforts over a period of years to invent various types of machines,
大约在1817年由一个名叫卡尔·冯·德莱斯的人发明，他是曼海姆市的一位德国小贵族。他出身于富裕家庭，但他实际上是一个修补匠和梦想家，总是热衷于尝试发明各种类型的装置。他非常感兴趣的问题之一是旅行，也就是如何在没有马的情况下在陆地上移动。因此，他在几年时间里做了很多努力，试图发明各种类型的机器，
of things he even called automobiles. But his most successful was this thing called the running machine. And the crucial breakthrough he made was to take two wheels and line them up in a kind of row one after the other. That is not to attach them to an axle and put them one across from the other, That is not to attach them to an axle and put them one across from the other separated by an axle, but to actually line one up in front of the other and connect them with a kind of a bar, which is sort of saddle, as he called it. And the rider
甚至包括他称之为“汽车”的东西。但他最成功的发明是这种被称为“奔跑机”的东西。他取得的关键突破是将两个轮子排成一排。不是把它们安装在车轴上并排放在一起，而是将一个轮子放在另一个轮子前面，并用一根横梁连接起来，也就是他所说的车座。骑行者
straddled his or her in this period, mostly his weight across the device and propelled it with a kind of scooting or skating motion by literally running, that is, by pushing off the pavement to propel the device. So this thing crucially did not have pedals. It was a pedal-less bike, and very quickly it began to spread across the continent, and then over the English channel in the England.
跨坐在装置上，在那个时期主要是男性，通过一种滑行或溜冰的动作来推动它，也就是通过脚蹬地面来推动装置。所以这个东西关键是没有踏板。它是一辆无踏板自行车，很快就开始在欧洲大陆传播，然后越过英吉利海峡传到了英国。
And there was sort of various short-lived crazies for this bicycle during this period. And then that leads us to one of the next sort of, you know, punctuations in this sort of evolution, the bone shaker, which came along in the 1860s. What was the big change that happened with the bone shaker? The big change for the bone shaker is that we got pedals, and these pedals, it was a direct drive device, so the pedals were attached directly to the front wheel of the bike. And this was, on the one hand, it was a very important breakthrough
在那段时期，这种自行车曾出现过各种短暂的狂热。这引出了演变过程中的下一个转折点，即19世纪60年代出现的“震骨车”。震骨车带来的重大变化是什么？震骨车的重大变化是我们有了踏板，这些踏板是直接驱动装置，所以踏板直接连接在自行车的前轮上。一方面，这是一个非常重要的突破，
that the thing would work better if it was a pedal-driven device, as opposed to one that you used your feet to scoot along the ground. But it was kind of an inefficient setup. And they called it the bone shaker, because it was extremely uncomfortable to ride. Its wheels were shod in iron, it was kind of ringed in metal. The machine itself was made of wood and iron. It was extremely heavy and you kind of like juttered and shook as you rode across the
即如果它是踏板驱动的装置，效果会比用脚在地上滑行要好。但这种设置效率很低。人们称它为“震骨车”，因为它骑起来极其不舒服。它的轮子包着铁皮，周围环绕着金属。机器本身由木头和铁制成。它非常沉重，当你骑着它穿过鹅卵石路面时，你会感到颠簸和震动。
cobblestone. So it was a machine that shook your bones. Mark Twain famously wrote about his attempts to learn to ride a bone shaker. And he said something along the lines of riding the bicycles, a great thing. You won't regret it if you live. So I think that speaks the fact that it was just, it was a pretty unpleasant way to travel because of the engineering. You read about how the next evolution of the bike was the penny-farthing bicycle, which is the bicycle with the big giant wheel, and it looks completely ridiculous today.
所以这是一台震动你骨头的机器。马克·吐温曾写过他学习骑震骨车的经历。他说过类似这样的话：骑自行车是一件伟大的事情。如果你能活下来，你不会后悔的。所以我认为这说明了由于工程设计的原因，这是一种相当不愉快的旅行方式。你读到过自行车的下一次演变是高轮自行车，也就是那种有着巨大前轮的自行车，今天看起来完全荒谬。
Why was that important to the bike's evolution? So the Penny Farthing bicycle is this remarkable looking machine. And if you see some hipster with a tattoo of an old-fashioned bicycle on his or her arm, it's going to be a Penny Farthing, right? With some sort of moustache and Victorian driving it. So yeah, the Penny Farthing was the bike with a huge front wheel and the tiny rear wheel. And again, it was a direct drive machine so the pedals were attached to the front wheel.
为什么这对自行车的演变很重要？高轮自行车是一种外观非常引人注目的机器。如果你看到某个留着胡子、手臂上纹着老式自行车纹身的嬉皮士，那一定是高轮自行车，对吧？维多利亚时代的人骑着它。所以，高轮自行车就是那种有着巨大前轮和微小后轮的自行车。同样，它也是一种直接驱动的机器，踏板连接在前轮上。
The reason that you have this quite remarkable looking, I think they're amazing looking machines. But the reason you needed this setup was because it supplied a gearing effect with every rotation of the pedal that turned the wheel one time, the larger the wheel, the greater the distance you would travel with each pedal turn. So you kind of get this absurd, almost steroidal front wheel in order to achieve a gearing effect. But again, this was a quite unsafe machine. It was very difficult to mount in the first place. The saddle sat quite high. It was at the height of a horse. This was the reasoning behind it. And also because you had such a big wheel, wheel by definition you were sitting high off the ground. And again it was just an awkward machine because you were using that same front wheel to steer
之所以需要这种外观奇特的设置——我认为它们看起来很棒——是因为它提供了齿轮效应。踏板每转动一圈，轮子就转动一圈，轮子越大，每次踏板转动你行驶的距离就越远。所以为了达到齿轮效应，你得到这种荒谬的、几乎像打了类固醇一样的前轮。但同样，这是一种相当不安全的机器。首先，它非常难上车。车座坐得很高。它和马一样高。这就是背后的原因。而且因为你有一个这么大的轮子，你坐得离地面很高。而且它是一台笨拙的机器，因为你用同一个前轮来转向
that you were peddling on. So people were prone to doing what they called taking a header that is flying over the handlebars, kind of pitching over the handlebars and injuring themselves in all kinds of gruesome ways. So something I had to give, because as cool as that bike looked, it was particularly a safe machine, and it sort of made the bicycle a device for sportsmen or daredevils, as opposed to a democratic machine that was a true form of mass transit. It wasn't exactly a commuter vehicle in the same way
和踩踏。所以人们很容易发生所谓的“翻跟头”，也就是从车把上方飞出去，向前栽倒，并以各种可怕的方式受伤。所以必须有所改变，因为尽管那辆车看起来很酷，但它并不是特别安全的机器，它使自行车成为运动员或敢死队的装置，而不是一种真正的大众交通工具。它并不完全像人们希望的那样成为通勤工具。
as it would have liked. Right. But Penny Farthing looks ridiculous now, but it wasn't just a novelty. exactly a commuter vehicle in the same way as you would have liked. Right. The penny-farthing looks ridiculous now, but it wasn't just a novelty. That big wheel was actually trying to solve a problem, but then a new technology came along in the form of the chain drive, which changed everything about what makes a bicycle a bicycle. So the breakthrough came around 1879 with the notion that you create a chain drive that is you move the pedals away from the front wheel to something like the middle of the bicycle
没错。但高轮自行车现在看起来很荒谬，但它不仅仅是一个新奇事物。没错，高轮自行车现在看起来很荒谬，但它不仅仅是一个新奇事物。那个大轮子实际上是在试图解决一个问题，但随后链条传动技术出现了，它改变了自行车之所以成为自行车的一切。所以突破出现在1879年左右，当时人们想到创造一种链条传动装置，即将踏板从前轮移到自行车的中部，
and you hitch a chain to a sprocket which is threaded back to the real wheel with each turn of the pedals. You pull that rear wheel forward and then that front wheel simply becomes a wheel that you steer with. You're not driving that wheel with the pedals attached directly to it. So this is a brilliant and innovative solution, which a mother, other things really takes advantage of the power of the human legs. That's the largest muscles in the human body are located in the legs.
并将链条连接到链轮上，链轮通过螺纹连接回后轮。每转动一次踏板，你就会拉动后轮前进，而前轮就仅仅变成了一个用来转向的轮子。你不再通过直接连接在上面的踏板来驱动那个轮子。这是一个极其聪明和创新的解决方案，它真正利用了人类腿部的力量。人体最大的肌肉位于腿部。
You know, the genius of the bicycle is that the rider is both the passenger and the engine of the machine. And a chain drive really optimizes that engine. But also, there were a number of other engineering breakthroughs in this period, so you had the arrival of a diamond-shaped frame, which is a sturdy setup. And you had two wheels of at first, more or less equal size, and then very quickly, after that, you know, identical size, which solves the problem that we had, and depending
你知道，自行车的天才之处在于骑行者既是乘客又是机器的引擎。链条传动真正优化了那个引擎。此外，这一时期还有许多其他的工程突破，比如菱形车架的出现，这是一种坚固的结构。起初有两个大小基本相等的轮子，很快，在那之后，轮子变得完全一样大，这解决了我们之前提到的问题，
far, they know if you know people taking a header,, all of a sudden, it's a much safer and more stable bike. And it moves much quicker and more efficiently. And here we come to, you know, the last great breakthrough, which is the development of not just tires that are that are rubber tires, but that have an inner tube filled with air, which provides a smoother and much faster ride. So suddenly, you have a machine which is truly a machine that anybody can ride, old people, young people, people have large frames, people who are small, you know, the so-called safety bicycle could bear the weight of a rider, you know, ten times the weight of the bicycle
人们不再会翻跟头，突然之间，它变成了一辆更安全、更稳定的自行车。它行驶得更快、更有效率。这里我们来到了最后一个伟大的突破，即不仅仅是橡胶轮胎，而是带有充气内胎的轮胎的发展，这提供了更平稳、更快速的骑行体验。突然之间，你拥有了一台真正任何人都可以骑的机器，老人、年轻人、体型大的人、体型小的人，所谓的“安全自行车”可以承受骑行者十倍于自行车重量的负重，
without any problem at all. So into that moment that we get the bicycle proper and then we get a kind of explosion of riding across the world. I love that the accumulation of all these inventions led to a thing called the safety bicycle. Just the name, the safety bike, it kind of cracks me up. Yeah, no, the name safety bike is funny. It's not the sexiest name, you know, it sort of sounds like you're underselling the thing. It's like a true safe, yeah.
没有任何问题。就在那一刻，我们得到了真正的自行车，随后世界各地掀起了一股骑行热潮。我喜欢所有这些发明积累起来最终导致了一种被称为“安全自行车”的东西。光是“安全自行车”这个名字就让我觉得好笑。是的，安全自行车这个名字确实很有趣。它不是最性感的名称，你知道，听起来好像你在低估它。就像一个真正的保险箱，是的。
Wow, it's safe, but it does bespeak that the enormity of the problem beforehand, because it really was the case that, you know, through the 19th century up until the mid 1880s, bicycles really were a kind of fringe phenomenon because they were viewed as unsafe, I mean, there were various other kind of reasons in the culture, social prejudices against the idea
哇，它很安全，但这确实说明了之前问题的严重性，因为在19世纪一直到19世纪80年代中期，自行车确实是一种边缘现象，因为它们被认为是不安全的，我的意思是，文化中还有其他各种原因，社会对女性骑行、儿童骑行的偏见，限制了骑行者的数量。但在这一时期之前，自行车被视为敢死队的东西。在震骨车和高轮自行车时期，自行车更像是宠物石或呼啦圈。那是一个层面的趋势。随着安全自行车的到来，
of women riding, children riding, which limited the numbers of riders. But prior to this period, bicycles were viewed as something for daredevils. In the period of the bone shaker and the penny farthing, bicycles were something more like, you know, a pet rock or a, like a hula hoop. It was a trend on that level. With the arrival of the safety bicycle,
你拥有了一个互联网规模的文化现象、社会现象，你知道，这是一场群众运动。到19世纪90年代，有数百万骑行者，数百万自行车通勤者在美国、西欧、英国和其他地方。是的。所以自行车在19世纪90年代兴起，并成为一种文化现象，但它面临很多阻力，你的书中有一整章内容，你知道，对自行车的一些负面反应，我想读一段，这是1896年《威奇托每日鹰报》的报道。自行车以一种新的角色出现，即曾经幸福家庭的破坏者。
you have like an internet-sized cultural phenomenon, social phenomenon where, you know, it's a mass movement. By the time you get to the safety bicycle, you have like an internet-sized cultural phenomenon, social phenomenon, where, you know, it's a mass movement. By the time you get to the 1890s, there are millions of riders, millions of bicycle commuters in the United States and in Western Europe, in the UK, elsewhere. Yeah. So the bike took off in the 1890s and it became this cultural phenomenon, but it faced a lot of pushback, and you have this whole section of your book with, you know, some negative responses to the bike, and I wanted to read one, and this is from the Wichita Daily Eagle in 1896. The bicycle has appeared in a new role, that of destroyer of a once happy home.
案例中的女性是阿尔玛·J·丹尼森夫人，原住布鲁克林第一街513号，23岁，一个骑男式自行车并穿着灯笼裤的“自行车女孩”。丹尼森先生说，他的妻子患上了“自行车热”，以至于她忽视了一切，她的家、她的孩子和她的丈夫。她只为她的自行车而活，并生活在上面。我的意思是，这听起来太夸张了，但你从当时的报纸中发现了这么多例子。为什么自行车面临这么多阻力？是的，在19世纪90年代，自行车有很多敌人。有道德和维多利亚价值观的守护者。有传教士和牧师在讲坛上抨击自行车。
The woman in the case is Mrs. Alma J. Denison, formerly of 513, Fist Street, Brooklyn, 23 years old, a bicycle girl who rides a man's wheel and wears bloomers. Mr. Denison says that his wife developed the bicycle fever to such a degree that she neglected everything, her home, her children, and her husband. She lived only for her wheel and on it. I mean, that just sounds like so over the top, but you found so many examples of this from newspapers at the time. Why did the bicycle face so much push back? Yeah, in the 1890s, the bicycle had so many enemies. There were guardians of morality and Victorian values. There were preachers and clergymen who invade against the bicycle from the pulpit.
有报纸社论认为自行车正在摧毁美国经济。正在把孩子们赶出学校，正在清空教堂的长椅。马匹贸易商、裁缝、雪茄制造商，甚至理发师都说他们的生意因为自行车的到来而被毁了，
There were newspaper editorials who thought that the bicycles were ruining the American economy. Were driving children out of schools, were emptying church pews. There were people in the horse trade, there were tailors, manufacturers of cigars, even barbers said that their business was being ruined by the arrival of the bicycle,
因为没人想再刮胡子了。不过，关于这一点，一个有趣的现象是“自行车狂热”或“自行车躁狂症”的概念。当时流传着很多关于自行车的伪医学观点，关于各种类型的疾病，你知道，心理上的或其他方面的，这些疾病困扰着社会，或者困扰着骑行过多的个人。所以，是的，当时有一种观点认为存在“自行车恶魔”或“自行车狂人”，他们因为过度骑行，
because nobody wanted to shave anymore. You know, an interesting thing though to note about this is this idea of a bicycle craze or bicycle mania. There was a lot of kind of pseudo medical ideas circulating about the bicycle in this period and about, you know, various types of diseases, you know, psychological and otherwise that had beset society or beset individuals who were riding around too much. So, so yeah, there was this idea that there were bicycle fiends or bicycle maniacs who, because of excessive biking,
本质上已经疯了。并且在做各种可怕的反社会行为。还有许多身体上的疾病和不适被归咎于自行车，从“自行车脸”——即如果你骑得太快、太久，你的脸会真正扭曲并改变形状——到你变得膝盖内扣或驼背。
had essentially been driven crazy. And we're doing all sorts of terrible anti-social things. And there were a number of physical maladies and ailments that were attributed to the bicycle, everything from bicycle face, the idea that as if you rode along too fast, for too long that your face literally contorted and changed shape, or you became, you know, knocked, need, or hunchbacked.
顺便说一句，这些文献不仅出现在大众媒体上，而且确实出现在那个时期的医学期刊中。自行车曾有一段时间是花花公子和业余爱好者的领域，但一旦进入安全自行车时代，它就变得政治化了。它在一百万种不同的方式上成为进步主义的象征。
And this literature, by the way, isn't just like in the popular press, but it's literally in medical journals from this period. The bike had this period where it was the domain of, you know, dandies and hobbyists, but as soon as you get the safety bike era, it becomes political. It becomes a symbol of progressivism in a million different ways.
它被用于抗议和社会运动。你能具体谈谈自行车在妇女选举权运动中的作用吗？我认为明确地说，自行车在这一时期被女性作为个人和集体解放的手段所拥护。在安全自行车到来之前，你知道，早期的自行车是一种非常性别化的机器。有一些女性骑过它们，但通常认为它是男性的机器，特别是运动员的机器。
And it was used in protests and social movements. Could you talk specifically about the role of the bike in women's suffrage? I think pointedly, the bicycle was embraced by women as a means of personal and collective emancipation in this period. Prior to the arrival of the safety bicycle, you know, the early bicycles, there was a very gendered machine. There were a few women who rode them, but generally it was thought to be a machine for men, for sportsmen in particular.
好吧，安全自行车显然是一种任何人都可以安全骑行的装置，包括女性，女性大规模地使用这种机器。如果你想想那个时期的美国、西欧和英国的女性，你知道，维多利亚社会中产阶级、上层中产阶级的女性，她们当时穿的衣服。如果你想想那种巨大的鲸骨束腰，当然还有巨大的箍裙，
Well, the safety bicycle-school was very clearly advice that could be written safely by anyone, including women, and women took to the machine on mass. If you think about women in the United States and Western Europe and UK in this period, you know, the kind of Oatboujwa middle class, upper middle class women in Victorian society, the clothing they wore at this time. If you think about what a big whale bone course, you know, of course it's our giant hoop
穿着那些东西走路都很困难，更不用说骑上自行车了。所以很快，想要骑自行车的女性说，好吧，我们必须换一些不同的衣服，所以服装改革运动确实是由自行车催化的。这就是所谓的“理性着装运动”。
skirts. It was hard to move around on those things on foot, let alone, mount a bicycle and ride one. So very quickly, women who wanted to ride bicycles said, okay, we've got to get some different clothing going here so that the dress reform movement was really catalyzed by bicycles. What was known as the rational dress movement.
所以女性拥抱了新型服装，包括著名的灯笼裤，那种MC Hammer风格的宽大裤子。因此，自行车在这一时期非常强烈地成为所谓“新女性”的象征，并与这些改革联系在一起。对于活动家、争取妇女权利、妇女选举权、投票权的鼓动者来说，女性不仅大规模地将自行车作为通勤工具。她们还将其用作抗议的工具。有自行车抗议活动，女性结伴骑行到路障前，为投票权等进行鼓动。
So women embraced new types of clothing, including famously bloomers, these kind of like MC Hammer style pantaloons. So the bicycle very much became a symbol of so-called new womanhood in this period and was associated with these reforms. And with activists, with agitators for women's rights, for women's suffrage, for the right to vote, women didn't just take to bicycles on mass as commuter vehicles. They used them as kind of tools of protests. There were bicycle protests where women kind of rode together to the barricades to agitate for the vote, et cetera.
当时有一种观点认为女性需要有监护人陪同出行，所以自行车突然解放了她们，让她们可以快速地在没有监护人的情况下四处走动。天知道她们骑上自行车后会做出什么事，去谁都不知道的地方，做天知道什么事。同样，那个时期的一切似乎都绕回了女性和性纯洁的问题上。
There was this idea that women needed to travel around with shaperones, so suddenly the bicycle freed them up to move quickly around unshaperoned. And God knows what they could get up to when they're on a bicycle, going who knows where, doing God knows what they could get up to when they're on a bicycle, going who knows where, doing God knows what. Again, everything sort of circles back to women and sexual purity in this period.
我的意思是，我真的很喜欢，你知道，如果你看看自行车历史，整个社会的神经质是非常明显的。这使得一切似乎都绕回了这个问题。展望未来，自行车在整个20世纪一直是抗议活动的固定装置。在你的书中，你引用了英国和北美许多抗议活动的例子，自行车在其中处于核心地位。但有一场抗议活动脱颖而出，那就是中国
I mean, I really like the, you know, the neuroses of society at large are very clear if you look at the bicycle history. It makes it at all, everything all seems to kind of circumnavigate back to this issue. Moving forward, the bicycle history, it makes it at all, everything all seems to kind of circumnavigate back to this issue. Moving forward, the bicycle was a fixture of protests around the world throughout the 20th century. And in your book, you cite many examples of protests in England and North America where bikes were front and center. But one protest stands out above the rest and that is China
1989年。你能告诉我自行车是如何成为天安门广场抗议活动的固定装置的吗？关于自行车，需要了解的一个关键事实是，它们是某种狡猾且难以捉摸的机器。你可以骑着它们穿过交通，你可以快速逃离，你可以骑着自行车相当快地动员一场抗议并迅速散去。它们实际上已经
in 1989. Could you tell me how bicycles became a fixture in the protests in Tanniman Square? One crucial fact to take on board about bicycles is that they're kind of sneaky and elusive machines. You can weave through traffic on them, you can get away quick on them, you can mobilize a protest rather quickly on bicycles and disperse rather quickly. And they've actually been
成为抗议的有用工具大约150年了，正是因为这个原因。这是我们在历史上的不同地点和时刻所看到的。但也许自行车具有最有趣政治轨迹的地方是中国，因为有一段时间它本质上就像是一种国家强制的旅行方式。我们有1949年的中国革命，此后不久，毛主席推动大规模制造自行车。他在中国自行车工业的发展上投入了大量的资金和精力。到了邓小平时代，比如20世纪80年代，自行车本质上正如我所说，是一种国家强制的装置，它被认为是每个中国人如果想要安家立业所需要的三大件之一。你需要有一台收音机、一台缝纫
useful tools of protests for something like 150 years because of this. And this is something that we see in various places and moments in history. But perhaps the place where the bicycle has the most interesting kind of political trajectory is in China because there was a good period of time where it was essentially like a state mandated mode of travel. We had the Chinese Revolution in 1949, very soon thereafter, Chairman Mao pushes for the manufacturing of bicycles on a mass basis. He puts a lot of money and muscle behind the development of a Chinese bicycle industry. And by the time we get to Denjiao Payne, like in the 1980s, the bicycles essentially, as I say, a state mandated device, it was thought to be one of three tools that every Chinese person needed if they were going to settle down and have a family. You need to have a radio, a sewing
机和一辆自行车。有几个极其著名的自行车品牌，主要是“飞鸽”，它有点像中国自行车的福特。然后邓小平说，你知道，中国每家每户都应该有一辆飞鸽自行车。到1996年，也就是中国自行车时代的巅峰时期，几乎每家都有了，当时有大约5亿辆自行车
machine, and a bicycle. There are a couple of extremely famous bicycle brands, chiefly the flying pigeon, which is kind of like the Ford of Chinese bicycles. And then Xiao Ping said, like, you know, there should be a flying pigeon bicycle in every household in China. There very nearly was, by the time we get to 1996, which is the kind of very peak of the bicycle era in China, there was something like 500 million bicycles
在中国道路上行驶。所以你问到天安门广场的抗议活动。好吧，在1989年，当然有这些学生领导的争取更大民主的抗议活动。好吧，北京的每个人都骑自行车，尤其是年轻人。所以天安门广场的抗议活动，将数十万人甚至最终超过一百万人带到了广场。那确实是自行车抗议活动，因为你有成千上万的人骑着自行车穿过街道，前往天安门广场，抗议活动本身
on the roads in China. So you asked about the Tiananmen Square protests. Well, in 1989, there were, of course, these student-led protests agitating for greater democracy. Well, everybody in Beijing rode bicycles, especially young people. So the protest in Tiananmen Square, which brought hundreds of thousands and eventually more than a million people into the square. There really were bicycle protests because you had tens of thousands of people sweeping through the streets, traveling to Tiananmen Square on bicycles, the protests themselves,
以各种方式使用了自行车。然后众所周知，当1989年6月发生镇压时，有自行车将伤员送进送出天安门广场。普通的北京市民把他们的自行车扔在军队的道路上，那些自行车将伤员送进送出天安门广场。普通的北京市民把他们的自行车扔在开进广场的军队坦克的路径上，试图阻止它们。所以从象征意义上讲，自行车，
used bicycles in various ways. Then famously, when the crackdown happened in June 1989, you had bicycles that were whisking the wounded in and out of Tiananmen Square. People regular Beijingers threw their bicycles in the path of the army bicycles that were whisking the wounded in and out of Tiananmen Square. People regular Beijingers threw their bicycles in the path of the army tanks that were rolling into the square in an effort to stop them. So symbolically, the bicycle,
几十年来它一直是广大中国人民的主要交通工具，但突然之间，你有了这种国家和军队的威力与这些笨拙的小自行车形式之间的对决。是的。好吧，所以你提到了自行车只是中国文化的一部分，而且它们
it had always been the main means of transportation for the Chinese people for decades, but suddenly you have this kind of showdown between the might of the state and the army and the form of these giant tanks rolling in and you had this kind of people's resistance with these pokey little bicycles. Yeah. Well, so you mentioned the fact that bicycles are just part of Chinese culture and they
被鼓励成为那样，并且应该出现在每个家庭中。事实上，全国平均每个家庭有1.5辆自行车。在某个特定时刻，确实有真正的协同努力将其转变为汽车文化。为什么以及它是如何发生的？是的，这是在后天安门时代，随着21世纪的到来，中国拥抱了他们所谓的“市场社会主义”，这种现在存在的真正超级资本主义的形式。这是一种权衡，因为中国政府向中国公民开放了各种以前无法想象的物质繁荣，但这种“浮士德式的交易”是，你知道，我们不会给你你想要的所有政治权利，
were encouraged to be that way and supposed to be in every household. In fact, there was like 1.5 bikes for every household in the country. There was a real concerted effort to turn it into a car culture at a certain point. Why and how did that happen? Yeah, so this is in the post-China man era, and with the turn of the 21st century, there was China embraced what they called market socialism, this kind of form of really hyper capitalism that is there now. It was sort of a trade-off because you had the Chinese government opening up various types of material prosperity to Chinese citizens that had previously been unimaginable, but the kind of fausty and bargain was, you know, we're not going to give you all the political rights that you want,
但我们会给你以前从未拥有过的各种物质财富。而这场运动的一部分努力，就像毛主席曾领导发展中国自行车工业的努力一样。好吧，他们说，我们必须进入汽车制造业。天哪，他们成功了，因为今天中国是世界上最大的汽车制造商和消费者。他们发展了一种汽车文化，使美国的汽车文化相形见绌，过去三十年在中国建造的高速公路和快速路网络几乎是美国州际公路系统的两倍。你有古老的城市核心，城市真正被重新设计，拆除并为汽车重新设计，巨大的八车道高速公路建起来，
but we're going to give you all kinds of material affluence that you've never had before. And part of that movement was an effort in the same way that Chairman Mao had led an effort to develop a Chinese bicycling industry. Well, they said, we've got to get into the car manufacturing business. And boy did they succeed because today China is the world's largest manufacturer and consumer of cars. And they developed a car culture which dwarfs that eat of the United States, the network of highways and expressways that has been built in China over the last three decades is almost twice the size of the interstate highway system here in the United States. You had ancient urban cores, cities really redesigned, raised and redesigned for cars, big, eight lane highways going up,
而以前你拥有蜿蜒曲折的中世纪街道，很容易骑自行车。中国大力追求汽车文化，突然之间，自行车，多年来一直只是生活的事实和每个人出行的方式。不仅受到阻碍，而且被积极地污名化。它在道路上被边缘化，而且骑自行车的想法也带有很大的社会污名，因为它被认为与糟糕的旧时代、与穷人联系在一起。
where previously you'd had twisty winding medieval streets that were easy to apply on bicycles. China went hard after car culture and suddenly the bicycle, which for years had just been a fact of life and the way everyone got around. Not only was discouraged, but was actively stigmatized. There was marginalized both on the roads, but also there was a lot of social stigma attached to the idea of riding bikes because it was thought to be associated with the bad old days, with poor people.
现在，在中国有一种回归的运动，一种回归自行车的转向，特别是随着电动自行车的兴起，这也许是汽车和自行车之间的一种妥协，是一种奇妙的装置。但是，是的，中国是一个超级有趣的故事，因为它确实，你知道，在中国自行车文化的那个巅峰时期，
Now that's, there's a kind of movement back in China, kind of a turn back to bicycles, especially with the rise of the e-bike, which is sort of a compromise, maybe, between automobiles and cars and is a kind of wonder device. But yeah, China is a super interesting story because it's really, you know, during that peak period of cycling culture in China,
你知道，中国被称为“自行车王国”。你在那里经历了一场疯狂的自行车热潮，持续了几十年，随后是对自行车的强烈抵制。而现在在世界各地，我们在美国和其他地方看到的是政策制定者，当然还有自行车倡导者和活动家，试图重建中国在这一时期相当有机地发展的自行车文化。所以我们都在渴望中国所抛弃的东西。
you know, China was known as the Kingdom of the Bicycle. And you have this kind of insane bicycle boom there, which lasted for decades, followed by this intense turn against the bicycle. And now throughout the world, what we're seeing in places like the US and elsewhere is a kind of attempt by policymakers and certainly bicycle advocates and activists to try and recreate the kind of cycling culture that China developed rather organically in this period. So we're all sort of lusting after what it is that China cast off.
所以是的，是的。在这一时期，我们都在渴望中国所抛弃的东西。是的。是的。你知道，自行车本身并没有什么政治色彩。在世界大部分地区，它是一种非常实用的机器。它只是出行的一种方式。它与政治无关。但很明显，自行车在许多不同的文化中意味着许多不同的东西。所以我从写这本书中学到的一件事是，时间和地点真的很重要。自行车没有固定的含义，即使在同一个城市内也是如此。在任何给定的城市，自行车可以象征身份象征或几乎是奢侈品。在城镇的另一部分，它可以是纯粹实用的，甚至是无产阶级的装置。它可以是抗议的工具，也可以是反抗议的工具。
So yeah, yeah. in this period, we're all sort of lusting after what it is that China cast off. Yeah. Yeah. You know, there's nothing inherently political about a bike. In big parts of the world, it's a very utilitarian machine. It's just this way to get around. It's unrelated to politics. But it's clear that the bike means a lot of different things and a lot of different cultures. So one thing that I learned in writing this book is that time in place really matter. There's no fixed meaning to a bicycle, even within a city. Any given city, a bicycle can signify a status symbol or almost a luxury good. In another part of town, it can be a purely utilitarian or even a device of the proletariat. It can be a tool of protest and it can be a tool of counter proletariat. It can be a tool of protest, and it can be a tool of counter protest.
所以如果你看看2020年纽约的“黑人的命也是命”起义，你会看到这些非凡的抗议活动，有成千上万的人走上街头，其中许多人骑着自行车，他们遇到了这些全副武装的自行车警察。纽约有一支精英自行车防暴警察部队，他们穿着那种忍者神龟、冰球守门员式的防暴装备。他们不仅骑着自行车，而且以各种方式将自行车用作武器。他们将自行车本身武器化了，所以他们把自行车当作盾牌，在某些情况下当作攻城锤。所以这是一个自行车含义在街头被逐个街区争夺的例子。这也是我想调查自行车并写这本书的另一个原因，因为自行车的内涵
So if you look at the Black Lives Matter uprising of 2020 here in New York, you have these remarkable protests where there were thousands taking to the streets, many of them on bicycles, where they were met by these kind of armored up bicycle cops. New York has, like, an elite division of bicycle riot police who were kidded out in these sort of teenage mutant
确实取决于你在任何特定地点是谁。所以把自行车是什么或骑自行车的人是谁归类是错误的。关于自行车有很多刻板印象和可能比较肤浅的想法，我希望能让其中一些变得复杂化。当我们回来时，在一个感觉像是为汽车定制的世界里，自行车的未来是什么？疫情确实动摇了很多人对城市可能是什么样子的观念。我们看到了像无车市中心和道路的新用途，为户外座位腾出更多空间。
ninja turtle, hockey golly type riot gear. And who not only were riding bikes, but were using bikes in various ways as weapons. They weaponized the bicycle itself, so they're using bicycles as kind of shields and in various cases as battering rams. So there's an instance in which the meaning of the bicycle is literally being fought out right there on the street, blocked by block. This was another reason that I wanted to investigate the bicycle and write this book, because the connotations of a bicycle
很多人自童年以来第一次开始骑自行车。你认为新冠疫情是否引发了对城市更大的重新思考？你认为这对自行车的未来意味着什么？是的，我认为疫情确实是一个关键时刻。所以世界各地有数百万人正在寻找一种社交距离的出行方式。
really depend on where and who you are in any given place. So it's wrong to kind of pigeonhole what a bicycle is or who a cyclist is. There's just a lot of stereotypes and maybe kind of shallow thinking around bicycles and I was hoping to kind of complicate some of that. When we come back, what is the future of the bike in a world that feels like it was custom built for cars? The pandemic really shook up a lot of people's notions about what cities could be. And we saw things like car-free downtowns and new uses for the road to make more room for outside seating.
自行车就在那里，你知道，自行车有一种回归的方式。所以突然之间，你有很多人重新发现了他们塞在地下室里的那辆三速自行车。或者注意到他们的城市有自行车共享计划，你可以订阅自行车共享计划或去租一辆，你知道，从街角的停靠站拉出一辆，你知道，以一种快速简便的方式在城里转转。我认为很多人发现了一些他们可能没有想到的事情，因为也许他们甚至没有尝试过，但骑自行车旅行确实非常愉快。
And lots of people got into cycling for the first time since maybe childhood. Do you think that COVID has led to a bigger rethink about cities? And what do you think that means for the future of bikes? Yeah, I think the pandemic really was a crucial moment for sure. So millions of people around the world were seeking a socially distant means of travel around town.
感觉非常好，你知道，这就像，你知道，一种身体上，你甚至可以说精神上，令人振奋的旅行方式。而且它也非常快速和方便，你知道，比坐在交通堵塞的盒子里，在喇叭声中出汗要有趣得多。至少你可以从盒子旁边穿过，或者在它们之间穿行。
And there was the bicycle, you know, the bicycle has a way of coming back. So suddenly you had lots and lots of people kind of rediscovering that three speed that they'd stuck in the basement. Or noticing that their cities had bike share programs and you could subscribe to a bike share program or go rent one, you know, pull one out of a docking station at the corner and, you know, get around town in a quick and easy way. And I think a lot of people discovered something that maybe hadn't occurred to them because of maybe they hadn't even tried it, but just it's so pleasant to travel by bicycle.
但我认为真正重要的是，在世界各地的许多地方，疫情期间临时搭建了基础设施。所以这些临时自行车道在许多地方变成了永久性的自行车道。有很多城市做得比我们在美国做得更好，很多地方做得比我们好。例如，我想到了巴黎，
It feels so good, you know, just it's like, you know, a physically, and you might even say spiritually, uplifting means of travel. And it's also extremely quick and convenient and, you know, a lot more fun than sitting in, you know, a box in traffic, sweating well, horns are blaring all around you. At least you can be cruising past the boxes or threading your way through them.
那里有现任市长，伊达尔戈是自行车运动的狂热支持者，这肯定让她在那里成为一个有争议的人物。但她凭意志力将自行车运动强加给了巴黎。那里的主要干道里沃利路，被默认变成了自行车高速公路。她有计划，那里有计划禁止汽车进入巴黎中心区的许多购物中心周围。所以疫情提供了这个，这是一种机会，因为突然之间更多的人骑上了自行车，但人们发现，嘿，这是一种很好的出行方式。而那些更
But I think what's really important is in many, many places around the world, there was infrastructure that was thrown up on the fly during the pandemic. So these kind of temporary bike lanes were thrown up in, which in many places became permanent bike lanes. There are a lot of cities that did this better, a lot of places that did this better than we did in the United States. So for instance, I think of Paris,
有远见甚至只是更激进的政策制定者和官员说，我们必须前进，抓住时机，推动其中一些事情。所以关于自行车未来会怎样，这很大程度上是未知的。关于这些事情有很多阻力，你知道，在纽约市，我们有一个计划，你知道，拥堵费已经获得批准，但由于各种官僚原因
where they have the current mayor there, and Adalgo is a Zellas proponent of cycling, which makes a controversial figure over there for sure. But she has sort of by force of will imposed cycling on Paris. The Rude Rivelli, a major thoroughfare there, is kind of turned into a default cycling highway. She has plans, there are plans there to kind of ban cars from a lot of the around these malls, the central districts of Paris. So the pandemic presented this, like, it's kind of opportunity because suddenly a a lot more people were on bikes, but people were discovering, hey, this is a real good way to get around. And the more
它还没有实施。人们对此非常抵制，因为，你知道，因为很多人非常依恋他们的汽车，而汽车文化本身在政治和其他方面是一种非常强大的力量。所以要让美国的城市看起来像北欧那些伟大的城市，比如哥本哈根和阿姆斯特丹，它们确实是自行车城市，还需要付出很多努力。但我认为在某些地方我们会达到目标。而且我认为希望我们能产生多米诺骨牌效应。
visionary or maybe even just aggressive policymakers and officeholders said, we got to move forward and seize the moment and push some of this stuff through. So as to what the future holds for biking, it's very much up for grabs. There's a lot of pushback about this stuff, you know, here in New York City, there's, we have a plan in place, you know, the congestion pricing has been approved, but for various bureaucratic reasons
有远见甚至仅仅是激进的决策者和官员们表示，我们必须向前迈进，抓住时机，推动其中一些举措的实施。因此，自行车出行的未来在很大程度上仍未确定。关于这些举措存在很多阻力，你知道，在纽约市，我们已经制定了计划，拥堵收费也已经获得批准，但由于各种官僚原因，
that it hasn't been implemented yet. People are very resistant to this because, you know because a lot of people are very attached to their cars and car culture itself is very powerful, powerful force politically and otherwise. So it's going to take a lot to make cities in the US maybe look like those great cities in northern Europe, which are places like Copenhagen and Amsterdam, they're really cycling cities. But I think in certain places we'll get there. And I think hopefully we'll have a domino effect
目前尚未实施。人们对此非常抵触，因为很多人非常依赖汽车，而且汽车文化本身在政治和其他方面都是一股强大的力量。因此，要让美国的城市看起来像北欧那些伟大的城市，比如哥本哈根和阿姆斯特丹那样真正的自行车之城，还需要付出很多努力。但我认为在某些地方我们会实现这一目标，并且希望我们能产生多米诺骨牌效应。
because people who visit those places realize just how much better it is to get around on a bicycle or a scooter or what have you. Anyone who lives in a city has probably seen an e-bike, a which is an electronic bike that you have some pedal assist. I guess you can use it without pedaling at all, but it basically makes it so that you can go up steeper hills and longer distances than you probably could on a regular bike.
因为去过那些地方的人会意识到，骑自行车、滑板车或其他代步工具出行要好得多。任何住在城市里的人可能都见过电动自行车，这是一种带有踏板辅助的电动自行车。我想你甚至可以在完全不踩踏板的情况下使用它，但它基本上让你能够比骑普通自行车更轻松地爬上陡峭的山坡，行驶更远的距离。
Are those here to stay? Will they be a big part of cycling's future? I think the advent of the e-bike is a really crucial development in all this because it's a lot less physically taxing to ride a bike. They're really amazing and I think people who might be resistant to sweating as they grunting the lawn as they try and mount a hill on a regular old bike. When they whiz up hill on a pedal assist e-bike, they suddenly, suddenly the whole world opens up to them. And moreover, this utilitarian value is definitely,
它们会一直存在吗？它们会成为自行车未来发展的重要组成部分吗？我认为电动自行车的出现是这一切中一个非常关键的发展，因为骑电动自行车在体力上的消耗要小得多。它们真的很棒，我想那些可能因为骑普通旧自行车爬坡时大汗淋漓、气喘吁吁而感到抗拒的人，当他们骑着踏板辅助的电动自行车呼啸上坡时，整个世界突然向他们敞开了。而且，这种实用价值绝对是，
it's like a cut above in certain ways. If you're running late for a meeting and you don't wanna show up dripping with sweat, you can get on an e-bike and get there in your suit, looking the part. So maybe the rise of the e-bike will be a crucial development, which will help bring about the cycling culture
在某些方面更胜一筹。如果你开会快迟到了，又不想弄得满身大汗，你可以骑上电动自行车，穿着西装准时到达，看起来体面得体。所以也许电动自行车的兴起将是一个关键的发展，它将有助于带来我们认为至少在城市中需要的自行车文化。
that I think we need at least in cities. You obviously love cycling and bikes, but you write about this phenomenon in the book called the Adaptive Golf. And it's kind of like how for some people, the dream of riding a bike is so far from what it's like riding a bike as a beginner, that it can be kind of hard to get into.
你显然热爱自行车，但你在《适应性鸿沟》一书中写到了这种现象。这有点像对于某些人来说，骑自行车的梦想与作为初学者骑自行车的实际体验相去甚远，以至于很难入门。
What do you think about that issue for people who aren't cyclists, especially in cities? I've seen that up close and personal in my own household recently because I have a nine-year-old, and we are in the extreme a cycling household. You know, my wife and I both get around by bike. My older son who's 18, tears around New York City on his bike. But for whatever reason, my nine year old has not been able to bring himself to learn to ride a bike. You know, like Daddy wrote a book about bicycles. You know, that's like, and yet, he's not into it.
对于那些不是骑行者的人，尤其是在城市里的人，你对此有什么看法？最近在我自己的家里，我近距离地观察到了这一点，因为我有一个九岁的孩子，我们家是一个极端的自行车家庭。你知道，我和我妻子都是骑自行车出行。我18岁的大儿子骑着自行车在纽约市飞驰。但不知何故，我九岁的孩子一直无法下定决心学习骑自行车。你知道，就像爸爸写了一本关于自行车的书，尽管如此，他还是不感兴趣。
So he's the passenger on my bike. You know, I actually have a special seat that I had to get from Holland, which is sufficiently sturdy to bear the weight of a nine-year-olds. Because in most cases, nine-year-olds have graduated to their own bicycles. But for him, it's that very thing, learning to ride a bike. It's actually extremely easy once you get the knack of it, but you do have to get the knack of it. And until you do, it's hard to imagine that you're going to be able to.
所以他是我自行车上的乘客。你知道，我实际上有一个专门从荷兰买来的特殊座椅，它足够坚固，可以承受一个九岁孩子的重量。因为在大多数情况下，九岁的孩子已经开始骑自己的自行车了。但对他来说，就是学习骑自行车这件事本身。一旦你掌握了窍门，其实非常简单，但你确实必须掌握窍门。而在你掌握之前，很难想象你能够做到。
I recently actually had lunch with a colleague, actually rather well-known journalist who writes for let's say a paper of record in New York City. I'm not going to name names, but he's an adult who's never learned to ride a bike. And I tried to tell him, dude, you got to get on a bike. It's very easy to do. And he, intellectually, he knows that he could learn
我最近实际上和一位同事共进午餐，他是一位相当知名的记者，为纽约的一家权威报纸撰稿。我不打算透露姓名，但他是一个从未学过骑自行车的成年人。我试着告诉他，伙计，你得骑上自行车。这很容易做到。他在理智上知道他可以学会
to ride a bike, but as you say, some sort of like conceptual golf that he can't cross in bringing himself to do it. Jody Rosen, thank you so much for talking with me. And thanks for the book. I really enjoyed it. It's just delightful. Thanks, Roman.
骑自行车，但正如你所说，他心中存在某种无法跨越的观念鸿沟，使他无法下定决心去做。Jody Rosen，非常感谢你与我交谈。也谢谢你的书。我真的很喜欢它。它太令人愉快了。谢谢，Roman。
It was so great to be here. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Jacob Moltenado Medina, edited by Chris Barube, mixed by a Medicanatra, music by Swan Riau. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall Kurt Colstead is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Vivian Le, Jason Dillion, Martin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Lashemadon, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, intern Olivia Green, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussion about the show on Facebook.
能来到这里真是太棒了。本周的《99% Invisible》由Jacob Moltenado Medina制作，Chris Barube编辑，Medicanatra混音，Swan Riau配乐。我们的高级编辑是Delaney Hall，Kurt Colstead是我们的数字总监。团队其他成员包括Vivian Le、Jason Dillion、Martin Gonzalez、Christopher Johnson、Emmett Fitzgerald、Lashemadon、Kelly Prime、Joe Rosenberg、Sophia Klatsker，实习生Olivia Green，以及我Roman Mars。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的Pandora大楼。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在Facebook上找到我们的节目并参与讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 999 PI org. On Instagram, Reddit and TikTok too. You can find links to others to church shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上也可以找到我们。你可以在99pi.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及《99PI》的每一期往期节目。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。